we have been interested in habits for a
long time and the reason is that so much
of our lives actually we are operating
almost on autopilot in our lab we're
trying to figure out what the basis of
those habits and so it was a wonderful
time when Theresa desrochers into the
lab I'm interested in habits and how you
form habits and a lot of people study
bad habits such as addiction I'm
interested in the kinds of good habits
that you have in your everyday life so
for example how you get to work in the
morning you generally will pick a route
and then you'll go on that route again
and again and again and you'll optimize
that route and I'm interested in how you
do that and then how you optimize it so
in this study we were interested in
having animals form their own habits
similar how to how you and I would form
habits and the way we did this is we
gave animals a grid of dots to look at a
grid of nine dots and all they had to do
was look around this grid to find a
rewarded target and the reason why they
form their own habits is because they
had a lot of time to do this and they
could look around in whatever way they
wanted to so what the animals did is
they made their own habit they made
their own way of getting to work as if
work was finding that rewarded dot and
what we could then use this for is then
being able to record in the monkeys
brain what was going on in the circuitry
that was underlying the formation of
those happens in this study we were
interested in recording from the stratum
because the striatum is implicated in
sequences and in habit formation
previous work in the lab had examined
how monkeys do sequences of cicadas that
were instructed and that were over
learned they found that there's this
activity that comes at the beginning and
at the end of the sequence and we wanted
to know if that was there from day one
so what we found is that neurons in the
striatum come to actually develop that
activity and as the habits that the
animal are doing are getting stronger so
too is that
activity previously with the same set of
animals we had done an in-depth look at
their behavior and found that it was a
notion of costs that could actually
drive the habit formation specifically
what cost is for these animals is the
total distance that their eyes travel as
they're forming their their own pattern
so when we were recorded that's one of
the first things that we were looking
for is this variable represented there
and it is and it's represented very
strongly at the end of trials so just
after the monkey finishes looking around
and finding that rewarded target that's
exactly when cells are responding to the
the cost that the animal had on that
particular trial it's amazing to sit and
listen to these cells as the animal is
actually working and have here this
giant burst of activity that's happening
at the end of the trial kenna memorial
was a postdoc in the lab when I was a
graduate student and he was really key
and figuring out a lot of the analyses
that we had to do with this huge body of
neurons that we had recorded when we
modeled the activity we said what other
variables can explain the activity
that's happening at in these neurons at
the end of the trial and we found that
there is a representation of cost as I
mentioned but also a representation of
reward we next wanted to know what
happens to this representation while the
animal is learning and what we found is
through overtime one of the populations
of cells the cells that respond to both
cost and reward together those cells are
gradually refining their responses so
they're becoming more and more refined
of exactly when they're firing at the
end of the trial and they're firing a
bit more strongly the animals behavioral
patterns are also getting more refined
they're becoming more and more habitual
becoming more and more ingrained and
repetitive and so these two things
develop in parallel and that strongly
suggests that this development in the
cells that are reflecting both the cost
and the reward are participating in
really driving the behavior and making
that behavior efficient everybody
probably has a situation where I have
this series of things that I do every
day and I'm going to be as
efficient as possible so whether it's
your walk to work or whether it's I'm
making my cup of coffee and I only want
to have to open the cupboard once you
are going to be very efficient about how
you do those things that you do all the
time and it feels very intuitive that
some notion of how much effort do I put
into this is part of how those behaviors
get there but nobody had really shown
that before so this is the first study
that really shows what the underlying
circuitry in the striatum could be doing
in terms of forming those behaviors and
supporting you becoming more efficient
at those behaviors that you do every day
you